so would you want to work
I'm I'm okay with not working I mean
yeah that's fine yeah see I you know and
it's funny because we talk about like
who bought the story and I feel like I
bought a lot of the story for years you
know I I really did I was like I was
somebody like I came out of college and
I was like I really didn't want to work
that hard I really didn't in fact I got
offered a great job with Lancome when I
first came out in a makeup company and
they were like you have to travel and I
was like oh no I'm not traveling for
work I don't want to do that I want a
sunbathe on the back you know and I want
to have my Summers
um but I did buy a lot of the story of
like don't lean on a man like it's
dangerous to lean on a man like you've
gotta like it was like an expectation
that Society had that I was gonna follow
some sort of work path so I think it's
interesting like to see all of these
women that do that and then land I'm
trying to like shake them like is this
something you really want or is this
something that you think you're being
told that you should want but in reality
inside you're like that's not for me